uh so a couple weeks ago we asked for
delivery driver submissions because we
have so many that watch
and we got we got a lot they're out in
the road listening to us
he's a beautiful young that's alan from
ohio
i'm a half filipino fedex driver so i
feel like this show is built for me
love listening to the show every friday
keep it up
thanks again helping me get through
quarantine i just got a quick debate
club for you
i'm getting married next week and my
fiancee's family and my family have
a difference of opinion on who's better
elton john
or billy joel let me know what you think
gang gang
buzz buzz buzz buzz young man that's a
tough one he does look like allen joe
bam bring him pick a picture island joe
man yeah who is this
and your man's fighting i don't know
what i i i think he should just dang
model sometimes when joe ban is in the
ring i feel like he should be one of the
ring
girls honestly you get an erection when
he's fighting
no dude yeah [ __ ] no i don't
i mean i will admit i'm a stone cold
model sometimes i look at his instagram
late at night though
but no uh just a look but no yeah just a
look man just passing by
yeah but dang that's a good call though
because
yeah you like dang man that boy bodied
up now
he has a fight too coming up does he
yeah he's pretty good
yeah he's good uh he's hard man
uh what is it he's a little elton john
or billy joel oh
versace versace
yeah legit model oh i think foreign yeah
yeah
that's where it comes from you didn't
know that oh yeah damn i just thought
dude if i was just good-looking i
wouldn't let people be
beat on me you know beating on you for
being ugly all marty ugly
but yeah i beat on myself you feel me
dude
late at night beating that meat ugh
brenden
kids listen to this show man kids that
probably are prepubescent man
jesus yeah he's a straight-up model dog
but uh billy joel or
elton john you said that did you already
say john
my mom's big elton john fence i'll go
ellen john
okay y'all liking that gay fella huh
that tiny dancer that tiny dancer oh
time dancer is good
bring him a picture of the other guy
who's the other guy paul simon you know
i like paul simon myself billy jones
ain't [ __ ] man
oh come on now oh billy joel did
crocodile rock or something didn't he
yeah that eliminated him right there for
me he did a new york state of mind i
really like that song
he just looks like an both of them look
like [ __ ] they do
that's fair ellen john got kids
yeah he's got a couple right in step
brothers horatio sans
plays the lead man the front man in a
billy joel cover band but they only
played late 80s billy joel and if you
request earlier in that oh yes
he attacked someone in the crowd what is
it uh step right
brother that's right it's so good that
seems so [ __ ] funny so i would say
probably i like uh
you know what i like man i realized the
other day man uh
men no
god damn time you realize that dude if i
was dating a man bro i would freaking
know
yeah you're right yeah if i was gay i
would know dog
i don't know sometimes you just hit you
nah man
but it would have hit me it would have
hit me again butcher box was really a
dick
you are gross brendon you are a girl i'm
an elm john fan doug
no you're not yeah i am i'm a poster of
them you have what a drawing of them
even nothing
yeah i'll draw them right now yeah you
can't draw elton john right now
yeah i could let's get some paper dude
yeah
yeah give it i'm going to actually i'm
going to kendra i'm going
old elton john too with the glasses the
hat the get up
dicks on his shoulder dude you can't
draw
yeah i can doug first of all i'm sorry
if you can
it's not going to get you any street
credit anywhere maybe outside of san
fran dude go get your elton john's
sketch on
you right you make millions out there
you like elton john huh yeah
he's good oh man you pandering bro
give me this [ __ ] give me something too
i'll draw a damn melting john you freak
do you guys want a reference photo or
just off the dome oh
phil collins i like phil collins
and i also went to high school with a
fella named phil collins dude yeah
i don't believe that and he had early
onset uh
alzheimer's i think or something or his
hair turned gray early remember
oh he did yeah i mean
whatever that is that is that
alzheimer's no what is it uh i don't
think so i don't think that's what it is
what is uh in the air tonight about it's
something crazy i can
feel it coming do we know what it's
about yeah what is it about
i thought it was something like it's
about cocaine
he wrote it about
maybe it's not about anything crazy i'm
excited to see these pictures though
yeah i know
well brilliant yeah brenda can draw
though yeah
i like elton john because the eminem
stan he did that at the grammys and like
he showed everybody that eminem wasn't a
bigot because they hugged oh yeah
when he was that's all it is yeah he's
got him give a [ __ ] a hug
that's all it is and then he also did uh
in the air tonight on lion king
yeah he did i yeah that's right
and he did tarzan can you feel the love
tonight
oh that was filled out one more you phil
collins
i was talking about aunt john oh okay
quick sketch of elton john that's good
damn that's where he goes like this dick
phil
it's like john vince brendan you curse
all the time yeah i do okay yeah well
your son's gonna watch this i got
sailor's mouth doug
this is mine right here
and that's what y'all get cause y'all
hoes bro
and i'm sorry for being rude to you guys
today man but you guys are [ __ ] hoes
what's a match
huh nuts everything
that reminds me of the whole gathering
sean connery on uh the
snl jeopardies like you just always
have some messages suck at your back so
let me see yours bro
are you hiding the art ability dude
that's pretty damn good do i do that in
about two seconds dawg yours took
way too long that looks like smoke my
nuts still smoke my natch dog
that looks like christopher columbus's
nerdy brother dude ronnie you grew up
with
that looks like ronnie columbus dude bro
you could never find america if you were
in a boat dude
not a chance bro they got gps now you
[ __ ] delete i'm talking about 2
000 years ago when christopher columbus
is here you idiot i would find it and
lie like he did
yeah right pretend like it's india yeah
look into it not sneeze on him kill
everybody
look into it yeah look into that boy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ]